hello everyone I apologize in advance if
I sneeze during this video I either
caught a cold or it's some sort of
allergies I have no idea either way if
it happens my bad I did have some rakia
before starting this video to counter
the sneezing but you know I don't know
if it will have much effect now this
game here I was played in 2015 it's
played between even charge of Croatia
he's playing against Maxim Bashir
allograph of France and it's a very
interesting even cherish won the 2014
challengers division of the Tata Steel
tournament and he he was awarded to the
privilege of participating in the 2015
Masters Division where he will face the
big boys this is definitely the
strongest tournament he ever
participated until that point and the
game is quite interesting and you know
what happens in the game is even more
interesting so we're gonna talk about
this tournament a bit more and about to
the results in this tournament but only
after the game so the correct answers
for the previous photo challenge of
course Sergei kirkin and niki riga and
for this photo challenge best of luck to
everyone who is the gentleman in this
photo so there we have it best of luck
to everyone now let's check out the game
shortage has the white pieces and he
opened with e4 as usual Maxime goes for
c5 as he was always known to be a
Sicilian expert and this will be quite a
quite a nice clash of styles as charge
is a well well known for his aggressive
style and attacking chest especially
against the Sicilian Knight to f3 d6 we
have d4c captures Knight captures Knight
to f6 Knight to c3 and a6 Maxime goes
for the knight or variation we have f3
now comes a 5 kicking the knight back
tonight b3 Bishop to e6 Bishop to e3 and
now Bishop to e7 Queen to d2 preparing
queenside castle we have castles Queen
side castles and the knight be d7 9b d7
now black is ready for his Queen side
expansion this night will either come to
c5 or better yet if if if black is able
to he will push b5 bring the knight over
to b6 and then the knight will be very
active on b6 so g4
our charge immediately immediately
starts his expansion on the King side
b5 we have rook to g1 and now nice to be
six so it's a pretty standard theme when
you have opposite side castles black
castle on King said white castles on the
Queen side now of course white wants to
attack as soon as possible on the King
side and black wants to attack as soon
as possible on the Queen side Knight to
a5 not allowing a 5 and b4 we have roped
the c6 preventing this knife from
jumping to c6 g5 now attacking the
knight Knight moves to h5 and now comes
King be one king we want always a useful
move especially since the rook is now on
the C file and of course as you can see
the Queen and Bishop are on this nice
diagonal so if okay at the moment Queen
Bishop and rook are guarding g5 but you
know it's just
anything can happen if this bishop ever
captures here you don't want your King
to be here on c1 so King b1 always are
useful move unless it's not but you know
g6 now we have a three now Queen to c7
and now Knight to d5 forcing some
exchanges with a knight captures on d5 e
captors on d5 and now black has to make
a choice either he will capture with the
bishop on d5 allow Queen captures and
then captured the knight on a 5
so basically Maxime could have gone for
this Bishop captures Queen captures and
then Queen captures on a5 about here
after c3 white pretty much stopped all
blacks plans then black will have to go
back and it will be very hard for black
to actually break through here because
you can never push a5 successfully the
Queen and Bishop are eyeing that b5 pawn
not not gonna be able to break through
here that easily so after e capture some
b5 Maxime went for Bishop to d7 not
allowing knight c6 we have h4 now
Bishop to d8 now with a double attack on
this 1985 and you can't really go back
because if you play a knight b3 then a5
becomes a possibility now the b5 point
is defended by the bishop on b7 and then
a4 b4 is coming so here shot each had a
different idea
he played
Knight to c6 okay but captors and c6
pawn captures on c6 and now Queen
captures on c6 and of course the thing
is if you capture on d6 with the Queen
then your a/c to pawn is under attack
but sure shed all of this plant first
bishop to h3 attacking the rook
you can always capture on d6 better to
improve your position first we have
looked the c7 and only now even captures
on v6 Queen captures on d6 allowing
Queen captures on C - Maxime captures on
c2 this comes with check King to a-1 and
now comes Knight to f4 so what do you
play here Bishop to g4 was played Bishop
to g4 preparing h5 we have before by
Maxine allowing rook to see one but
Maxine had all of this figured out he
decided he will sacrifice a piece here
Queen to b3 and here Charlotte plays
Bishop captures on f4 it seems like the
rook and c7 is free for grabs because
after Bishop capture screen captures
Bishop not really after rook captures on
c7 the Bishop captures on c7 Queen
captures on c7 you get B captures on a3
there's the threat of checkmate on b2
and after you block this then comes pawn
captures with Czech Queen captures and
now you lose the bishop on e3 so before
starting anything first charge plays
Bishop captures unnies on f4 not
allowing the bishop on e3 to remain a
target we have it captures on f4 rook
captures on c7 and here Maxime doesn't
even bother capturing the rook first B
captures on a3 already threatening
checkmate on B to rook to g2 and now
comes Bishop captures on c7 Queen
captures on c7 and now rook to b8 and
this is the critical moment of the game
Maxime is down a piece so Charlotte says
is up a bishop but there are the pawn
the Queen and the rook are all piling up
on this poor B to pawn
so here it's its move 31 and it's not
it's not time trouble or anything
sherry said I believe he had some 40
minutes on the clock still so here with
the Queen to see one black doesn't
really look that really have any
means of continuing this attack a captor
sambito with Czech rock captures and now
black can't push for anything he would
have to settle for a draw here a queen a
four check roblox Queen D four check
roblox we need four check roblox and
then we would have a draw by repetition
of moves but here
sharukh has a moment of blindness and he
plays rook to d2 roof to d2 is a move
that loses the game immediately why does
it lose the game immediately well feel
free to pause the video here and try to
figure it out churches of course of
course
threatening rook to d8 this would come
with shirk he would be able to exchange
rooks and then he would be perfectly
fine but he missed one very important
idea so I will give it a couple of
seconds if you want to try to crack this
position what moved it sorry to miss in
this position so for those of you who
were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
player and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show here a captures
on b2 is played okay that's just the
first move you cannot capture because
then Queen captures would be checkmate
but King could be one what's played and
now comes the move shot each missed the
movie Irish missed was Queen - a - check
and now you can see the horror that the
King has to capture if you don't capture
if you try to escape
I don't simply be 1 this comes with a
double check from both Queens you have
to move check moves and this will be
checkmate so you would have to capture
the Queen here King captures but now
after the other point is promoted to a
queen now the Queen and rook are
connected and it's an easy checkmate
King a 3 Queen to b3 checkmate so
although this was a after this rook to
b8 move it's a perfectly safe position
for white White has plenty of time on
the clock but you know for some reason
you miss that quint way to move and you
lose the game horribly so a very nice
victory for maxumcorp sherrilyn Grove
and a very tough defeat for 4 even
charge and here we have the standings
after the final round of the 2015 Tata
Steel masters division here you see that
Magnus Carlsen has won the tournament
with 9 out of 13 points and the maxim of
a holograph came in second with 8 and a
half and this
point against even cherish really got
him a long way all across event ruled
England Wesley saw punished giri and
then he got second place because he had
a much better additional criteria so
here you see even charged all the way
down on the bottom with a four and a
half out of thirteen points but as
you've seen from this game you know it's
something that happens to all of us you
know i've had games against strong
players against weak players in
tournament play where i would play a
move like roof to d2 and then i would
say yeah man I probably shouldn't play
chess you know at all but did that stop
even charge of course not today in 2018
he is the reigning champion of Croatia
he is also the reigning European
champion by winning the the European
Championship he won the privilege of
participation in the World Cup and if he
does really well in the World Cup
I believe if they haven't changed
anything the two top contenders of the
World Cup get tickets to the to the
candidates tournament so if anyone does
really well perhaps we'll be seeing him
even more in the candidates tournament
so yeah that's it
will this be a prelude to today's match
Croatia vs. France it's hard to say
hopefully Croatia will not blunder like
even did in this game but you know we
just have to wait and see that's you
know that's that's the great thing of
you know just being able to enjoy things
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it and I really hope we'll enjoy today's
game it starts in about three hours and
some 15 minutes from the time I'm making
this video I would like to thank Matteo
Botti Lucas our Fernando Estella the
Oliviera stanislav petrov and the james
eroding for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with another
interesting video thank you